so Bernie Sanders is either taking a
call it like I see it approach with
Donald Trump's idiocy or he simply
gotten pushed over the point at which
he's sick and tired of the idiocy of
this administration but he is now being
targeted because he was so mean to trump
on Twitter and so unpresidential because
he said Donald Trump's belief or at
least statement that climate change is a
hoax makes him an idiot that that's
quite simply what he tweeted over the
weekend quote Donald Trump believes
climate change is a hoax Donald Trump is
an idiot oh no
what Ameen unpresidential immature thing
to say about stop the concern trolling
okay you these concern trolls have no
leg to stand on you should pay no
attention to them remember that as this
was happening Donald Trump was tweeting
basement-dwelling conspiracy theories
about Jeffrey Epstein and the Clintons
he was having a two month old orphaned
baby brought back to a hospital for a
sick photo-op with him and Melania if
the argument is that bernie is
unpresidential in this tweet what about
Donald Trump's years of attacking people
and ideas and the truth on Twitter
endlessly in a completely irrational and
unpresidential way you have no leg to
stand on
trumpets don't really care about
unpresidential on Twitter because if
they did they'd never have voted for
Donald Trump in the first place or at
minimum would have stopped supporting
Trump by now Bernie is right Trump is an
idiot but I actually don't believe Trump
thinks climate change is a hoax in
reality Trump thinks that dealing with
climate change accepting it accepting
that humans are impacting it making
policy as a result of that acceptance
would be bad for him and for the
businesses of his friends a period in
the meantime Trump insists it's a hoax
and it does convince a lot of people
that it is straight-up a hoax people who
have nothing to gain by the way from
pretending that it's a hoax like Trump
and his friends do but I actually
believed Trump knows climate change is
not a hoax I don't think he really
understands the specifics of it he
doesn't seem to read anything he doesn't
seem to listen in-depth to any issue but
I think that this is for his own game
that he asserts that it is a hoax and
people get convinced by it and the
concerted effort to suppress information
about climate change and climate science
is too much for just believing that it's
a hoax it's what you need to do when you
know it's not a hoax but you've got to
pretend it is by covering up all of the
serious information about it which
they've been doing within the USDA
they've been doing it within NASA
they've been doing it elsewhere and I
want to sort of flip this around anyone
who's not taking climate change
seriously as a matter of policy must be
ridiculed it would be immoral not to
ridicule Donald Trump whatever his
sincerely held belief is about the
climate change issue for even
propagating the idea that it is a hoax
he needs to be ridiculed it is immoral
every single day we're falling further
behind in actually dealing with the
climate crisis every day Trump is doing
the opposite of what should be done not
publishing research from his own
administration but rather suppressing it
not strengthening standards on vehicle
efficiency and more but rather weakening
them and this is actually super
straightforward it's not the language we
might have expected in politics ten
years ago Donald Trump is an idiot from
a 70 something year old senator but this
is the Trump era this is not a
theoretical discussion about whether or
not
Bernie should or shouldn't be using this
language the content of Bernie's tweet
is effectively accurate if the argument
is it's not presidential language go
talk to Trump about his language because
he uses that language all the time but
if you are focused on the language
you're ignoring that Bernie Sanders is
right about the critical reality of
dealing with the climate right now Trump
is not doing it and I say good for
Bernie and people you know people call
in and say David do you think that the
Trump presidency
even after he's gone is going to
maintain an effect and the answer is yes
Donald Trump's presidency even after
he's gone will open up the door to more
Trump like ignoramuses
to be elected to office state local
national wherever because they are seen
as legitimate voices in the political
discussion which they should not be they
should be laughed at again as I said if
Donald Trump wasn't given a small loan
of a million dollars to start a business
his ran things would be the thing you
would expect to see from the guy who
just urinated on the subway tracks
before going back underneath the stairs
while yelling at everybody who's down
there but he's in a different position
because of a financial thing so that
that has been legitimized that idea
these types of people have been
legitimized as politicians with valid
voices by the Trump administration not
that everyone shouldn't be heard but
just because someone should have the
right to vote doesn't mean that they
should be President of the United States
we're talking about two different things
and the corseting of the language quite
frankly I don't think there's any
putting the genie back in the bottle or
putting the toothpaste back in the tube
so to speak with the sort of discourse
that has become legitimized over the
last few years and it's not just going
to be Republicans who sort of take to
that discourse so what I say is on the
subject matter on the merits good for
Bernie and the criticisms about it being
the wrong language well go and talk to
Trump about the wrong language